opposers if you're like me you woke up
an hour and a half ago to a victory
Republicans are waking up to a victory a
win in that state's 8th congressional
district Debbie Lesko the projected
winner in a special election here's the
thing and a race that on paper really
should have been a blowout it ended up
at a single digit margin oh yeah baby a
single digit the number one as in the
Republican one granted let's go one by
five points in a district Trump won by
over 20 so this race was a little closer
than it should have been but so was
Emmanuel macron all day yesterday and I
got to tell you that went well
see the left keeps talking about a
supposed blue wave in the upcoming
midterms Republicans have all the tools
to crush it this fall just look at their
fundraising Republicans are worried
about a blue wave they also have a
reason to fear a green one as well
Democrats are out fundraising Republican
incumbents so far political reports that
at least 43 House Republicans have
raised less money than their Democratic
challengers have shut it of course
Democrats raised more money they needed
to buy that super expensive milk that
comes from cows were organic grass-fed
and have audible accounts not me I get
my milk from the most dumb cow in the
barn
Republicans don't need money just look
at Morris County New Jersey where the
local GOP held a fundraiser featuring
Fox personality Greg Gutfeld as the
keynote speaker
now they paid Gregg thirty thousand
dollars and all in the event cost
$64,000 but it was worth it because they
brought in a whopping less than that so
now their entire war chest is down to a
little less than 14 grand but 14 grand
that's more than enough I went online to
see who they could afford to hire for
their next fundraiser and let's just say
we might be seeing appearances from the
likes of Rockapella
Liza Minnelli look-alike Suzanne Goulet
or my favorite Right Said Fred this this
is why I'm not worried about the
midterms we have all the money and
energy we need and as far as a blue wave
is concerned I can assure you the water
is very calm and very red like super red
someone might have had an accident in
the water
[Music]